hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well so
today the government shutdown sort
i mean the street lights are still
working
that's local government the mail is
still coming
checks are still being processed the
army didn't go on for a low
but you know national parks closed a lot
of employees got sent home on furlough
or being asked to work with no pay
the promise of getting paid later on
is this a good or bad thing overall well
if you're a utilitarian how would you
figure this out
what are the key things that we have to
do in order to
analyze whether it's a good or bad thing
despite the put all of the politics
aside from one you know whether you're
like the democrats or the republicans
let's just think about
overall is it a good or bad thing to
close the government every once in a
while
so what would have to look at yeah
okay so we have to look at people
um that's part of the people affected
yeah maybe the programs that got shut
down or didn't receive funding
again somehow it affects people that
they would otherwise benefit
so people benefited
by the programs okay that's another
important set of stakeholders as we call
them
what else yeah
that depend on like national parks and
things like that
okay so people
involved
and let's call these cascade
economies you guys know what a cascade
is
it's when you have like you know one
thing and then that falls and it knocks
a whole bunch of other things down then
that knocks even more stuff down think
of like a
an avalanche where like dominoes all
falling that's a cascade effect
so when a federal government program
closes in an area like a park
um they're no longer getting the money
that would be going out into the local
economy
so that means a local economy has less
money they're negatively affected
then you know that local economy might
affect other local economies that's a
cascade
anybody else that's benefited or harmed
by government shutdown
yeah well members of congress don't have
to do anything but they're still getting
paid
so they benefit in a sick way
yeah um
they're more or less just staying the
same they're getting their their
benefits no matter what
so they're not really changing when we
talk about like political benefit you
know
what the parties are getting out of it
because both parties are actually doing
a lot of grandstanding right now
and consolidating their bases so they're
both getting something something
effective yeah
i would say like all the citizens in
general because they rely on the
government for security
okay so knowing that the government is
shut down like they have to feel now
like that they're in a vulnerable
position as well or like their country
and all the people in the country i
suppose but this shutdown
doesn't affect any services that are
considered vitals armed forces are still
in place i wonder if the center for
disease control
is fully staffed i imagine it probably
has to be but like nasa everybody
just about everybody's gone home for
dancing because we don't actually need a
space program
to have national security or you know
like border traffic agents those people
are all there
the uh the airport the
tsa people they're all still there so
it doesn't affect that so much does it
affect citizens
as a whole in any way
positively or negatively
the government is not spending money the
way it
is the way it was just last week
is that changing
maybe not immediately
what about taxpayers
are taxpayers as taxpayers as people
putting in money
are they negatively or positively
affected by
a shutdown yeah um maybe negatively
because
you're not getting the same services
well there won't
already be people benefited by the
services
but let's think about let's take a local
example property taxes
um you're paying property taxes
as most of you will be when you buy a
home
which will probably be you know in the
next 10 years
your property taxes are going in part
to you know like pave roads and pay for
police and things like that
municipality but what are the bulk of
property taxes for
usually school
what if you don't have any kids in
school
is a reduction in property taxes good
for you or bad for you if you have kids
in school
then obviously you know you're probably
not happy about the property taxes but
unless you're getting something out of
it
if you're the childless couple you know
in the the expensive house
uh and you're paying a lot of property
tax say 8 000 bucks a year or something
like that
you're probably going to be saying what
am i supposed to be getting for this
other than police protection
and pothole fixing the chance to vote
for mayor
you might actually be happy to see less
money being spent
um and there you know there's probably a
lot of taxpayers
that would like to see government spend
less money in both parties actually
republicans usually want to cut back on
the total budget democrats usually
are willing to concede that there's a
lot of waste in government
a lot of wasted money so maybe that's a
group that's positively affected
so how would we weigh this thing
let's think about these different groups
again so the people who are out of a job
they're government employees they're not
going to be happy are they
they're happy that they get a little you
know vacation time but it's unplanned
vacation time
a furlough is not quite the same thing
as getting to go to jamaica
or you know key west or something like
that it's
you go home and you don't get paid so
that's
negatively affecting them in in some
pretty serious ways what are the numbers
does anyone know offhand yeah
yeah which sounds like an awful lot
people out of something like 2.3
million government employees u.s
government employees not state
local just u.s government employees
so it's about what a third yeah about a
third of them
you had your hand up oh um
what do you think the number of people
benefited by
these different programs let's think
about what's actually closing so
state parks
during this time available in new
language like that
could be a lot of people because okay
which area are you talking about are
they federal parks they're going to
yeah okay new england
i usually think of state parks but
uh like you know gettysburg will be
closed i'm assuming
yeah smithsonian can't go to the white
house on a tour
what else i suppose yellowstone
big places like that okay so so that
could be quite a few people
affected what else uh nasa's closed
so if you wanted to go tour a space
center or something like that it's
it's off for right now but is that
really
affecting a lot of people probably not
um
now that could be big for like you know
the cascade stuff
um what else is closed
and then shut down yeah i was reading in
the wall street journal that uh
the irs had to cancel so audit
don't know the implications of that it
could kind of be pretty bad for
it could be good for some people but
yeah majority
um i imagine for anybody who's like
lined up for an audit that's probably
good news right
because you know the irs
does want quite a few people and
sometimes they're on track and sometimes
they're not
there's been a lot of discussions lately
about some of these proper audits
so maybe that one's a neutral one
uh so the irs what else is closed
what else actually yes
well that's what led up to this big
crisis because they they didn't want to
fund the republicans didn't want to find
the health care bill
and the republicans and democrats right
now are terrible at getting along and
thinking of the common good
so neither one wants to compromise and
this is a way to like not pay for a
massive
expansion in government spending
but since it wasn't funded in the first
place it's not like anybody was losing
out
any other things that are major that are
getting close
because of this yeah about our borders
those are still
being being controlled that's one of the
essential features
that just like the military that they're
at least for the time being still
they're
still paying attention yeah but like
passports are being effective
yes if you want to get a new passport
now that's going to be a big
inconvenience
again how many people does that really
affect probably not that many right now
you only need a passport every 10 years
so maybe this isn't that large this is
probably a lot larger
people infected by the cascade economy
you know you can ask yourself do they
have sort of a right to an expectation
that the government should keep pumping
money into these these things and it
should keep falling out
and then you know how big is the
taxpayer base
pretty big i mean once once you get out
there and start paying
taxes for real you know you'll find out
that
it's not quite so much fun you know and
you wind up in these higher and higher
brackets over time
where you pay a larger amount then you
start actually
thinking well maybe they're spending too
much of this money on these things
and caring more about that maybe here's
what we'd have to ask ourselves
does the positive benefit
for these people outweigh
the negative harm to these people
and notice that some of these people are
in that taxpayer bracket so they sort of
cancel each other out
you know they take some people out of
that
we would actually have to ask if this is
a good or bad thing putting all the
politics aside just looking at it in
terms of finances
we'd have to get some more numbers i
think we'd have to find some ways to
quantify
how much harm is being done to these
people
how much benefit is happening to these
people
notice too that the benefits of these
people it's not going to happen right
away
if your tax bill goes down eventually
because of the government shutdown
because the government didn't spend as
much money when is that going to happen
tomorrow end of the year
could be a couple years before it
happens so maybe
it's not that much benefit to the
taxpayers
maybe this is more of a bad thing
overall than a good thing